elle a l'apparence des boks que l'on
trouve dans les consignes de gare sauf
qu'il s'agit bien d'une boîte aux
lettres une partie pour le courrier
l'autre pour les colis c'est parce qu'il
en avait marre de faire des allers
retours à la poste pour son travail que
son inventeur plombier de formation a
décidé de créer cette boîte xxl j'ai
besoin d'aller dépanner un client
parallèlement j'attends de pièces une
livraison et je ne peux pas rester sans
c'est au bureau et perdre des heures de
travail
donc c'est très pratique et war recevoir
son colis car on n'est pas au bureau
cette boîte aux lettres s'adresse donc
aux petits artisans mais pas seulement
aux particuliers aussi noël bernard a
déposé plusieurs brevets pour protéger
son invention le secret de la balle
échos réside dans son mécanisme de
verrouillage qui lui a valu une médaille
d'argent au concours lépine un livreur
qui vient chez vous peut ouvrir la porte
pour déposer un colis
ensuite il a fermé la porte et surtout
la verrouiller une fois qu'elle est
verrouillé le comportement était
utilisée et on peut plus
le réouvrir noël bernard a investi 60
mille euros pour lancer la production de
la balle et qu il a trouvé un
sous-traitant ici à nazelles négron
actuellement on a lancé une première
série de boîtes d'une certaine des
pièces simplement par la suite on aura
un délai qui va tourner autour de 2 ou 3
semaines puisque l'atelier ici que
produire beaucoup plus de boîtes en deux
mois noël bernard a vendu une trentaine
d'exemplaires de sa balle aequo avec la
progression de la vente en ligne
il espère pouvoir se faire une place sur
le marché il se vend 2 millions de
boîtes aux lettres chaque année en
france